[Música]
eu não sei se vocês conhecem uma
bibliotecária
eu não sei como você imagina uma
eu não sei se vocês pensam no coque no
óculos em silêncio da biblioteca na
calma mas é bom eu sou bibliotecário eu
sou professora do curso de
biblioteconomia e me chama mariana ohata
e eu ia biblioteconomia temos em comum a
curiosidade a curiosidade informacional
a curiosidade contudo que corresponde
que relaciona com a informação certa vez
eu compartilhei uma notícia de uma vaga
de emprego com um grupo de amigos de um
emprego maravilhoso uma vaga maravilhosa
com vários benefícios vários privilégios
o emprego que talvez eu mesmo que
quisesse e ele logo depois eu recebi de
volta uma mensagem de um amigo que tinha
recebido a mensagem dizendo que essa
empresa nem existia e eu descobri que eu
tinha um grande problema
fui pesquisar porque que eu a
bibliotecária diferente ou nada tinha
compartilhada a informação falsa e foi
tentar entender o que de fato é uma
informação falsa
cheguei ao conceito de desinformação
a desinformação é uma informação falsa
é uma informação falsa em precisa
enganosa a este tipo de desinformação
chamamos de bice formation quando a
informação é falsa em precisa e enganosa
feita propositalmente chamamos de miss
information chamamos de desinformation
já quando a informação é falsa em
precisa enganosa feita prepara opositor
aumente para prejudicar alguém ou seja
com um prejuízo a alguém
chamamos de mau information sabendo
desse tipo de desinformação e
contexto em que vivemos não sei se vocês
já ouviram falar sobre fake hills está
bastante na moda fitness é um tipo de
desinformação sabendo sobre o tipo de
desinformação sobre as formas de
desinformação e sabendo que eu tinha
compartilhado uma informação falsa
eu procurei também entender qual é o
contexto porque que eu compartilhava eu
a biblioteca cara diferente tona que
sabe avaliar todas as informações estava
compartilhando uma informação falsa e aí
procurando conhecer e reconhecer o
contexto informacional eu vi que existem
algumas características que colaboravam
com esse tipo de prática informacional
uma primeira característica é a
hiperinformação a desordem informacional
eu não sei vocês mas eu no meu celular
tem várias fotos que eu mesmo não
consigo organizar o saber até que
existem e pela informação essa noção de
hiperinformação ela ela conversa ela
dialoga com s com excesso de informação
que nós usamos criamos compartilhamos
sem que possamos nos dar conta
a outra noção é são as são é entender
que as informações elas são feitas antes
de tudo por pessoas somos nós quem
fazemos a informação somos nós quem
compartilhamos criamos e usamos a
informação
uma outra característica relacionado ao
contexto informacional são as
tecnologias de informação e comunicação
e aí talvez alguém aqui pensa assim a é
sabia que era culpa da internet toda vez
que ouço falar sobre fake news
eu sei que a culpa da internet ou da web
e não é a internet a web as mídias
sociais que nós usamos na verdade elas
promovem elas propiciam o uso
compartilhamento ea criação de
informação e informação verdadeira ou
informação falsa ou qualquer outro tipo
de informação
uma outra característica desse contexto
informacional é a noção de pós verdade e
após verdade ela funciona mais ou menos
assim quando eu era criança minha mãe
sempre falava assim pra mim mariana
senão vai comer manga com leite eu nem
gostava de manga e eu tinha uma certa
aversão ao leite
ninguém me perguntava se eu queria comer
mamão manga com leite eu só ouvi você
não vai comer manga com leite e esse
tipo de reprodução da informação na
verdade servia para que as pessoas para
que ela naquele momento
compartilhar comigo as crianças e as
opiniões que ela tinha em ao menos
observar os fatos e saber se de fato se
daquele modo aquela informação significa
alguma coisa se a manga com leite de
fato fazer a mão
uma outra característica é estar
relacionada à a visibilidade da
informação falsa a informação falsa ela
tem seis vezes mais chances de serem
compartilhadas do que as informações que
não são falsas e aí eu trago um exemplo
que quando a gente está na internet
acontece bastante que uma pessoa coloca
um post uma frase polêmica alguém logo
comenta assim fulano fulano você lakro
esse lacre está ligado à polêmica e aí
talvez as pessoas não se preocupem tanto
e verificar a informação e se preocupam
mais e criar compartilhar ou usar a
informação que pode causar polêmica e
com uma informação falsa tem mais chance
de ser compacto compartilhada criada é
usada
as pessoas tendem a usar mais informação
falsa para se tornarem mais polêmicas
relacionando a noção de desinformação
contexto informacional e que eu enquanto
bibliotecário trabalho
eu puxei olhei observei a noção de
competência em informação competência em
informação é a promoção das dinâmicas
críticas e éticas do contexto
informacional para diferentes
comunidades em diferentes contextos para
a promoção da cidadania
seria isso a competência informação na
área de biblioteconomia e da ciência da
informação a competência em informação
ela vem sendo estudada mais de 40 anos
mas nos últimos 15 20 anos diferentes
iniciativa
vem acontecendo relacionadas à
competência informação uma iniciativa
foi a proclamação do do barack obama
presidente dos estados unidos à época
barack obama sobre a necessidade de
sermos competentes e informação para o
exercício da cidadania
uma outra iniciativa é a chamada mil
cliques da unesco em que a unesco fala
sobre a competência e mídia e informação
e uma terceira iniciativa que colabora
com este contexto de promoção da
competência informação foi a publicação
do relatório sobre desinformação da
comissão europeia em que ela fala que a
competência em informação surge como uma
possibilidade uma alternativa para
diminuição de desinformação
estou falando bastante sobre a
desinformação competência em informação
e olhar crítico para informação mas é
importante saber que olhar criticamente
diferente de analisar criticamente
eu particularmente no meu dia a dia eu
sou bastante crítica eu tendo a olhar as
coisas e pensassem bom isso é verdadeiro
e isso é falso
isso é certo está errado isso é bonito
isso é feio
pouco importa a minha opinião quando eu
falo de informação eu não posso pensar a
partir da minha opinião eu preciso
analisar eu preciso ter a mente aberta
eu preciso saber que eu não tenho o que
eu tenho preconceitos sobre alguma coisa
eu preciso reconhecer os meus
preconceitos e aprender com eles
eu preciso reconhecer as minhas crenças
e minhas opiniões e aprender com elas eu
preciso saber que eu não sei tudo sobre
tudo está tudo bem quando isso acontece
eu preciso também saber que eu tenho que
aprender a aprender ea cada dia eu terei
novas oportunidades de aprendizagem
isso é analisar criticamente uma
informação e aí para avaliar a
informação eu proponho que nós
observamos a informação a partir de
cinco perguntas e essas perguntas elas
não funcionam como
feita de bolo sob o risco de não dar
certo se eu não fizer a pergunta uma
pergunta 2 depois a pergunta 3
essa receita vai solar não é assim que
funciona eu preciso ter essa informação
irmão num determinado contexto sabendo
para o que eu preciso daquela informação
porque eu preciso daquela informação
feito isso eu faço ou mais perguntas
para reconhecer e avaliar a informação
a primeira pergunta que eu faço a
informação seria o que essa informação
qual é o objetivo dessa informação
quando eu faço essa pergunta eu entendo
que a informação é sempre menos uma
coisa do que mais alguma coisa
a informação tem limite a informação tem
de limitações
ela tem uma proposta ela tem enfim uma
finalidade
uma outra pergunta que eu faço a
informação é porque porque essa
informação a quem ela presta a quem ela
vale porque eu quero essa informação
porque eu preciso dessa informação
a terceira pergunta é quem quem fez essa
informação quando eu pergunto quem eu
quero saber a propriedade intelectual a
responsabilidade intelectual por essa
informação eu quero saber com quem eu
estou conversando com quem eu estou
discursando com quem eu estou dialogando
a responsabilidade intelectual está
ligada na maioria das vezes ao autor ao
produtor ao distribuidor e ao
patrocinador
quando eu reconheço quem eu ver com isso
que a informação é feita por outras
pessoas
essas pessoas podem ser pessoas físicas
como eu uma pessoa como eu como cada um
de vocês ou pode ser uma empresa uma
instituição uma organização sempre
existe uma carga ideológica quando eu
falo de pessoas pessoas não combinam com
não ideologia pessoas têm ideologias
pessoas são parciais
as informações têm ideologias
informações são parciais
a quarta pergunta que eu posso fazer é
quando
quando essa informação foi publicada
e aí quando eu respondo quando eu
procuro saber a data é data que a
informação foi criada usada e
compartilhada ao reconhecer o quando a
reconhecer ao reconhecer a data eu
consigo vislumbrar essa informação é
atual ou nova oi a atual e nova
atualidade novidade são de tem
definições diferentes pois nem tudo que
é atual é novo assim como nem tudo que é
novo é a atual área da medicina por
exemplo pode usar fontes de informação
informação que foram publicadas hoje
pela manhã e que o e que nesse horário
já não são mais atuais
ela já podem ser consideradas diz
atualizadas embora não sejam novas
porque foram produzidas hoje foram
publicadas hoje
já a área da história por exemplo pode
trabalhar com informações que já são que
já não são novas são antigas por exemplo
de 1.500 1.600 não são novas na data
podem ser novas para alguém mas podem
ser atualizadas porque nenhuma outra
informação pode ter desatualizado
por fim a última pergunta que eu posso
fazer é onde e quando eu pergunto onde
eu quero saber em qual mídia foi
publicada que a informação foi veiculada
aquela informação e qual o formato por
exemplo o jornal x y z
ele vai representar cada um desses
jornais ele eles representaram o tipo de
ideologia de parcialidade e eu também já
consigo reconhecer o que é aquela
informação
quando penso na mídia eu preciso
entender que uma tese de doutorado por
exemplo terá obrigatoriamente um nível
de exaustividade de densidade diferente
de um artigo científico ou de uma
notícia de jornal
uma outra resposta que eu posso ter
encontrar quando pergunto onde é também
complementar as informações
uma informação ela pode ela pode por si
só não bastar para ir para a necessidade
que eu tenho para informação que eu
preciso então eu posso procurar outras
fontes de informação que me ajudaram a
xvii
a informação que eu preciso agora que
nós já falamos sobre desinformação
competência em informação e avaliação de
fontes de informação
eu proponho que nós pensemos na
reconstrução da universidade a partir da
informação
a universidade assim como a informação
era uma construção social ela requer a
participação de todos
ela quer ela requer que todos nós
tenhamos responsabilidade e
solidariedade no seu uso no seu
compartilhamento ou na sua criação
a universidade é uma responsabilidade
minha
de cada um de vocês e de todos nós
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]